we've all seen plenty of Batman action
figures but have you ever thought to
yourself they aren't big enough well it
sounds like this action figure might be
for you an upcoming Batman statue from
NECA stands at six feet and two inches
tall and is based on Batman from
Rocksteady's latest Batman game Arkham
Knight some of the key details are
unfortunately unknown at the moment but
here's what we know from any ca's block
the six-foot two-inch figure is made
from foam rubber latex and uses a fabric
for the cape the design was created
directly from the digital files used in
the making of Batman Arkham Knight it
ships in two separate boxes and acquires
some very simple assembly that isn't
described there's no date for when they
will start accepting orders nor do we
know how much it will cost or how much
it weighs
whatever the particulars it's throughout
March 2016 so more details are on the
way I'd prefer something that fits on my
shelf and won't scare friends and family
but hey to each their own hopefully
we'll find out more soon but for more
video game and giant actions of your
news you're already in the right place